you can go to work every day and
separate yourself from anybody else and
it's no different than the sound guy on
this set if you pick up you know what
this sound guy is really really good and
he's worried about this and he's worried
about that then all of a sudden you tell
somebody you need a good sound guy this
and then they end up on this person
because of a recommendation all of a
sudden this guy is known as the best
sound guy in L.A because he's paying
attention or she's paying attention to
details that the other sound people
don't no you know what I hear an
ambulance out there let's cut it you
know just a little little bitty things
and I just think that it's easy to
separate yourself from anybody else no
matter what your position is if you go
to work for a company and you don't go
up the corporate ladder it's your fault
it's nobody else if you're either with
the wrong company where there's no
upward Mobility you should separate
yourself because I know one thing if you
work for me I'm paying attention nothing
goes unnoticed okay and I tell people
that all the time if you want to
separate yourself it's easy to do
because somebody above you is going to
notice it your peers are going to notice
it is easy to separate yourself from
anybody else hey it's Evan Carl Michael
and I make
I make this I struggle to stay afloat I
quit my business partner and the thing
that kept me going was studying the
stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe your life and learn how to
stop doing what poor people do enjoy
[Music]
the best things that I ever did was I
will I will look at somebody's resume
and I can say you know what you've never
been with the right company and that's
why you haven't excelled and and you are
that's why you're in here today and so
many people choose the wrong company to
go to work for and I look at people all
the time and I look at your resume and
say why did you go to work for this
company I knew they were screwed up when
you went to work for them okay and so
some people just are not good at
choosing the right company and also the
person interviewing makes promises that
never happen and I think that's one of
the biggest mistakes that people make is
choosing the wrong company to go to work
for curiosity what makes something the
wrong company to go to work for is it
different by person or are there just
certain things in a company people
should look out for well do they really
have good liquidity are they going to be
in business are they an acquisition
Target where all of a sudden that they
are and you're going to get bought and
probably laid off uh you know everything
is is uh are they in do they have a
product that is going to be around for a
long time so everything from liquidity
to product acquisition Target growth of
where are you going to go everybody
should always ask themselves if they
want to grow and they just don't want to
just whatever is is say where can I be
in five years if I can't be at this
position in five years then this isn't a
good career path for me I think
everything is career path rule number
two is remove bad friends with Alex
hermosi I have shed friends every season
of my life my close Circle has always
been very very small very very small
very very small
very small not
I also feel like I grow really quickly
because I don't hold on to things long
the moment something doesn't provide me
value I shed it I think about my life in
three to five year Seasons first I was a
high school womanizer for the most part
and then I was also like really deeply
angry I had high school friends that
when I left high school I'd basically
stopped being in contact with them and
then I had my come to Jesus where my dad
was like you suck as human you have a
terrible reputation maybe you should
stop being who you are cleaned up my ACT
I stopped drinking nearly as much as I
was I started going to school and
studying 12 hours a day present the
fraternity and that was my college
season and I had College friends and
then when I left College I pretty much
stopped being in contact with anyone
that I went to college with most people
suck at most things and aren't Bound for
greatness because of who they are and
the choices they're willing to make the
stories about friends leaving the
hometown and no longer remember where
they're from is one that is told by
Society because Society is the majority
the majority of people get left behind
if you look at the things that you want
to get in life there's a price for them
you don't buy everything you see in the
mall why not because you don't want to
pay the price just because you might
think that a shirt or jacket is cool
just because you think an outcome is
awesome you might not be willing to make
the trade winners and losers have the
same goals the goal doesn't make you
unique it's the willingness to pay the
price that makes you unique something
like everyone wants to be rich one of
the reasons that I cut people out sooner
than most is because I do not like the
labels they speak over me one of the big
things with identity is the labels that
we say about ourselves I am ex I am
impatient I am angry I am whatever right
I am poor I don't like saying it people
in your past have the identity that they
know you as and then they will speak and
they will beat that label into you
because you're not matching their
pattern why have you changed you are X
you are why and you're trying to not be
that because you're doing something
different than changing you're growing
but they see it as change and that's why
the best response in the world of
someone who says hey you've changed is
to say yeah you have it the amount you
like or love someone is directly
proportional what you are willing to
give up to maintain the relationship for
example if there's a piece of your car
right you work on it all the time you
might say that guy must really love it
because of how much time he puts into
that thing this guy must really love his
country because he's willing to give his
life for it what are you willing to give
in exchange to maintain the relationship
if you're not willing to give up
basically anything to maintain their
relationship
then how much do you love them I think
it's been a very helpful filter for me
to say not do I love my friends but
which friends do I love the most which
friends am I willing to sacrifice the
most to keep the relationship and I am a
big believer in utility there is an
exchange in every relationship you get
something and they get something back
people don't like the idea that
relationships are transactional
but they are transactional just has a
commercial vibe to it but if we just
think about it as from a behavior
standpoint you've got two things that
can happen a behavior is reinforced or
it is punished that's it when you have
exchanges quite literally with people
those exchanges are either reinforced or
they're punished part of the strength of
the relationship is how long you're
willing to wait for the next time that
relationship is reinforced if you have a
long history of positive experiences
with a person you're willing to wait a
longer period of time if they're going
through a breakup they're having a hard
time to keep the relationship going but
at some point even if you've been
friends with somebody for 10 years if
there's just not any positive
reinforcement at some point
you do cut it off the people who are
surrounded with when we grow up it's
very unlikely just from a population
standpoint that they're going to be
great statistically that they're going
to be the top one percent or point one
percent is unlikely so it would make
sense that you change your friends over
time why do people get so weird about
keeping relationships that don't serve
them I think it's just because we have a
societal story around it that you're a
bad friend but I could also think of me
being as a good friend to my next friend
that I just made room for there's gonna
be a friend who's going to move in to my
spot on my buddy's calendar who does
want to do fantasy football who does
want to drink with him on Sunday so it's
not this like all right I'll go to the
game with you but I'm not drinking oh
dude you're not gonna come on man
because the other guy's like yeah shots
all around they're gonna have a blast
they would better be served with people
who want the same things as them just
because I'm not seeing them anymore
doesn't mean that I don't wish them well
but if someone only tells you the
stories when you got [ __ ] up and while
you did that stupid thing they're
encouraging you in retelling the story
of who you used to be and you want
people around you who don't believe the
lies you used to tell about yourself the
character trait shift is not a binary
it's how patient are you how kind are
you how loyal are you how honest are you
and so you want people who encourage you
in the behaviors that you want to be
like and this is why I like shedding
identities is such a core part of
Entrepreneurship is that you have to be
willing to say I am no longer this way I
will no longer behave in this way and I
don't accept that reality as truth many
of the people I had around me hey
weren't willing to pay the price that I
was willing to pay for the things that I
wanted but also wanted me to give them
more than I was willing to and so I'll
give you a story that will paint me in a
bad light and that's fine there was a
teacher that I grew up with in high
school and he's the one who stayed with
me after school for a year and worked
out with me two hours a day and you
taught me how to work out I got in shape
got more confidence better at school
from there that snowballed into me
getting into fitness huge Catalyst
snowball somebody heard that story and
then found the teacher and they linked
us he was like hey man I'm not asking
for a lot I would love to just have like
a two-hour quality every week
that was like two hour call
every week
I was like I don't even talk to my
mother that much I don't talk to anybody
that much talk to my wife that's it the
value of the relationship was in the
past you may be like Alex you're a
horrible person and that's possible
maybe I am I was not willing to give two
hours a week 100 hours a year for the
rest of my life
to pay a debt for somebody who worked
out with me because we only have so much
Juju we only have so much time we have
so much Focus so much energy that we can
pour into things and if you're not
putting all your energy in One Direction
it's scattered and then you don't move
as fast my closest friend I spent one
hour a week with every week my closest
friend like clockwork it's my highest
party meeting it is something that
brings me joy and we get lots of
exchange with one another he's the one
who helps me write my books Dr Kashi Dr
Kashi here I get a lot from that now if
I didn't get anything from that over
time slow down the communication between
us I would make it every other week once
a month if you slow down your
communication cages with someone how
frequently you see them and when you
accept invitations it naturally Fizzles
but if it gets to a point where if
someone's like so close that it would be
obvious and a conversation needs to be
had
I encourage you to just have it you want
to be a kind person and the way you are
kind is that you tell the truth and you
just be honest and the easiest way that
I can tell you to be honest is you know
when you talk about somebody behind
their back just say it to them it's like
yeah Sandra's been like all over the
place lately and she's like I don't
drink it a little bit too much Sandra
you've been all over the place lately
you've been drinking a little bit too
much I'm just not sure if I want to
associate with that right now people
just don't have the balls to do that but
if you do that I promise you you either
have better relationships or you'll be
done with this Mickey Mouse [ __ ] of
not even being in a real relationship
and not wanting to confront reality
because you may have a shot at getting
them to realize that they're not on the
path that they wanted to be on because
you were friends with him at some point
and so either your goals have changed or
theirs have if you listen to Kobe's
interviews where he talks about his
friends he says very explicitly that
he's willing to put everything on the
Altar for his dream now some people may
make the argument that's not quote
healthy the question that we're
answering here is not how do we do
healthy stuff question is how do we
become the greatest people will judge
you on how you spend time and their
judgments are simply Expressions that
they would not spend their time the same
way you do hey you work a lot and I
could say hey you don't to the same
degree it's like you spend so much time
with your kids
right if I say it like that people like
wait no I'm supposed to it's only the
supposed to this the thing that gives
all the emotional charge to these
conversations otherwise it's just
observing reality you can't expect to do
the same thing everyone else is doing
and then somehow achieve a different
outcome once you have the vacuum of
friends because you'll probably have
weeded people out then the best thing to
do is join communities and then you'll
make friends people in those communities
who have the same goals as you and then
if you crush it because you understand
that volume is the answer and time is
the ingredient you're going to rise in
that community and you'll gain more
status and you'll start hanging out with
people who are the top of that community
and then you can LeapFrog into other
communities it's just lunch tables on
steroids I've wanted to live a rare life
and so I will have to be surrounded by
Rare people and rare people are by
definition rare they're not common My
Hope Is that the people that I meet now
are trying to go all the way with me I
want to do epic if I die and don't do
epic I will be bummed how much am I
willing to endure or sacrifice in order
to maintain that relationship that I
have with my dream if I have many many
friends over different seasons I'm
totally cool with that thank you for
that season it was awesome I don't
believe things need to be forever to be
good rule number three is leave the
comfort zone with Dean graziosi I'm
reading an Incredible Book right now
called The War of art not the Art of War
the war of Art and I would suggest it to
anyone and you know if you've been
watching me for years you know I talk a
lot about this villain that's created
inside of us well Sam I forget Sam's
last name right this moment it'll
escapes me but the author of The War of
art talks about it as resistance so I
want to I want to share this with you
today that resistance is that thing that
happens that makes us procrastinate it
makes us in today's world surf the
Internet instead of working on our
passion it's what makes us say I really
love to do that but it's a hobby when it
really could be what you do full time
and enjoy yourself more resistance is
that if you ever try to write a book and
you sit down and you check your email
and your bank accounts and text a few
people first because you're not sure if
you could make that happen it's talking
about following your dream and quitting
that job and trying something new but
you don't it's that same thing that I
call the villain that Society is built
up inside of us so Society may have done
it rules and and limiting stories that
were told to us as kids may have done it
but it lives inside of us and we're the
only ones that can defy it so I was this
morning I was literally working out and
I had the earphones in and I'm listening
to resistance and I got goosebumps a
couple times because resistance if you
look at it as a foe as someone that you
have to overcome somebody that you want
to beat someone you're not going to let
win kind of changes the game a little
bit it's almost like we get to be two
different people when you when you're
passionate about something
let me give you an example uh right now
I I a couple months ago I went with Tony
Robbins who's a good friend and I spoke
in China and Japan with him and I was
nervous I was scared to death it's a
different country it's a different world
it's a different language I'm going to
be on stage in front of 18 000 people
Tony doesn't put many people on his
stage I love the guy I want to I want to
deliver to him I was a nervous wreck and
when I look back at it now it's because
there was resistance and that resistance
is good when you're nervous that's good
when you do the same thing over and over
what do you get you get bored that's why
you don't like your job it's why things
get mundane it's because you're not
putting you're not fighting that
resistance now I'm I'm sharing this with
you today and I'm getting on a plane
right now I mean when I'm done here
getting on a plane and going to
Australia to speak on stage again with
Tony now I'm a little nervous because
it's different and I gotta adapt but
that resistance is I could go no no it's
different but no it's it's it's actually
exciting and and here's the thing that I
think we all you know and if you're
watching me for years you know I talk
about this stuff in different ways but
when we overcome resistance
and we try something when we realize
that whether it fails or succeeds we
succeed
because sometimes do you know anybody
maybe yourself that talks about I'm
going to write this book and when I do
it's going to do this and this and this
and if I but you talk about it so much
that you talk all the way through the
success but you also talk your way and
oh what if it fails what if I look like
a loser what if I write my first book
and no one buys it what if it doesn't
get published or what if I start that
new company and and I'm not smart enough
I'm not good enough so resistance starts
telling you all these stories and it's
easier to just talk about what you're
going to do the resistance is there
because of Life telling you just conform
do what everybody else does don't step
out of the box too much the resistance
is there thinking it's going to protect
you when really it's holding you back
from being the best you possible uh Mike
who who's been filming me for years I
said what did you think about this he's
like well I got that all the time but
how do I overcome the resistance so
here's what I'd like you to do this week
not only look for the resistance look
for that villain telling you you can't
or stopping you or teaching you to
procrastinate or or maybe you haven't
addiction and I'm not going to go down
like I know how to cure addictions but
sometimes these things happen because we
want to go this way and we feel the
resistance and we don't want to do it or
feel that villain telling us we can or
society's words are this limiting story
we just go let me go here for a quick
High whatever that is whether it's sex
drinking drugs work addiction gambling I
don't know what it is but sometimes that
flow so how do we get it and power
through that resistance who stands in
our way and what I'd like for you to
think about this week is be the Observer
of your thoughts I've been saying that
for years
and when you decide you really want to
write that book start that new company
start the exercise routine learn a new
language be a better parent and
something's holding you back identify it
don't just get the habit of going well I
don't feel like I'm going to go here
because that's what our bot we get used
to and our brain has this flow and it's
like we're going to try and it will go
over here I'd like you to stop in your
tracks be the Observer of your thoughts
and say okay if if resistance had a
voice
what would it be saying and write it
down and then I'd like for you to say
I know this is simple we've been talking
about things like this for years is it
true
and if you're not sure Google it get
some leverage That's Tony Robbins word
get some leverage sometimes we say you
know I let's just use an example of
writing a book I know how much
resistance I had when I wrote this this
was my first book totally fulfilled guys
I was in special reading till 10th grade
I didn't go to college because Mrs
Thompson in seventh grade because I
couldn't spell and I couldn't sound out
words she would tell me once a month
sound it out are you stupid I mean those
those words ring in my ear so I just
always thought I was stupid and didn't
even consider going to college I'm a
special reading I'm stupid I was judged
by an outdated scorecard I was great in
a lot of other things but I just felt
stupid because I couldn't read but when
I was going to write this
do you know how much resistance I had I
put this off and put it off and then I
started reading other people's books I'm
like oh my God I can't read their books
they're so much smarter than me then I
did the first version of this book I
gave it to an editor and she literally
said I can't edit this this is a 200
Page conversation you need to rewrite
the whole book I'm like oh there it is I
was right I am too dumb but it was all
resistance with these lies but no if you
read this book I had a message to
deliver yes it is a 280 page
conversation but it's a pretty damn good
one
but resistance almost stopped me so what
is stopping you what resistance is
stopping you from the life you're
supposed to be what if I didn't write
this book I I might be doing something
great but I wouldn't have gotten my
first New York Times bestseller and
propelled me into doing these weekly
wisdoms and real estate books and real
estate education around the world right
so
this week identify give a voice to that
resistance write it down and ask if it's
true and if it isn't true then how can
you listen to a lie and if you think it
might be true Google it you know is it
true that someone who barely graduates
high school who's in special reading who
has no formal education who never took a
damn class on how to write a book who
was broke when he wrote the book it was
just a transition period of my life who
never got a book published is it true
that that guy could write a book and get
it published and It produced all over
the world and be a New York Times
bestseller yeah it happened here it is I
didn't have any favors I didn't have any
friends in the book business I didn't
have somebody else I wrote every word in
this book
now I'm not talking about me like a
Dean's great I'm just talking I want you
to see that there's more for you and
don't let this damn resistance hold you
back also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is don't have a
scarcity mindset with Tom bilyu how did
you change your mindset to do the hard
things in the gym and get up when you
didn't want to when so many people don't
do those things what allowed your or
what tools did you use or what practices
in order to stay committed because a lot
of people they're just not committed
over a long period of time so how did
you have that when other people didn't
uh to answer that question I have to
take you back so
now it was about 15 years ago I had this
sense that I was stuck in The Matrix and
my life could be something more but I
know how to make it more right and part
of that was on a day when I wanted to
stay in bed when it was warm I did yeah
uh and then time just feels like it's
getting away from you and you haven't
really identified that the the problem
was that you didn't have something
specific enough to get you out of bed
right you weren't setting goals you
didn't have a vision you weren't
executing on your dreams you might be
dreaming like I was dreaming I've always
dreamed for me Ambition was never the
problem I was the most ambitious laziest
person you're ever going to meet 15
years ago right and it was realizing
wait just because I'm lazy by Nature
doesn't mean I have to be lazy in
actuality like I can actually get the
discipline to develop real drive to
acquire those skills so when I met the
guys that are now my partners they put
me into a scenario where there was a
very real world
um consequence both positive and
negative for living up to the
acquisition of skills so and and that
environment that gladiator pit that I
ended up stepping into is the business
world and the great thing is when you're
no longer an employee and it's your
business and everything you have is on
the line and if the business fails you
lose your house like that that's real
yeah it's real to you in a way that it's
not to an employee right because now
there's a real consequence that goes
beyond well I have to look for another
job right this goes into I could lose
everything if I can't solve this problem
now that can scare you away and keep you
wanting to be an employee where it's a
little bit safer or that can be wildly
motivating to you and that was
interesting to me so I wanted to be able
to say the harder I work the better
result I get and they gave me the
opportunity to plug into business where
that became true if I could solve these
problems if I could build a better
product if I could Market it better
whatever that better results came and so
there was like now a connection between
how hard I work the skills I acquire and
the reward I get and that that was all I
needed and then for me being in that
Loop allowed me to do things like the
gym sure so when did you discover your
new values and one of those values
personal and then business and they
intertwine yeah yeah for me they're
totally connected 100 and that's by
choice because for a long time they
weren't connected the way that I got the
value system was truly looking at what
works right and um so I believe that
um I'm going to give away my answer to
something you're going to ask me later
about I believe that the the purpose in
life to be great you have to
um acquire as many skills as you can
that have utility and then put that
utility to the test because now you can
see did I actually get the skill that I
thought I got did I get the result from
that skill that I wanted and you can
judge both what skills you need to
acquire and whether you have effectively
required them and business like that is
the closest thing to say MMA fighting
right MMA is you want real-time feedback
on whether you're learning and getting
good at something let someone whose sole
intent is to take your head off come in
and test whether you can defend a choke
or defend an arm bar it's so real and so
visceral there's you know you can think
of it there's either it's pure metaphor
or there's no metaphor right like you
were in that moment so finding ways that
business can can be like that for me
allowed me to create a set of values out
of pure efficiency so when for me I the
one thing I can't I can't give you
ambition I can't make you want something
right I can't want it for you but once
you want something now you plug into
something very real and if you accept so
that I talk about this 25 bullet points
is the quest belief system and that was
me trying to give people the thing that
they needed to escape the matrix and in
that is the belief that you can acquire
skills that the human mind and human
potential is nearly Limitless right so
you start putting all this stuff
together and it's like okay essentially
everything falls on my shoulders if if I
want to be great it's all down to me and
whether I execute on that or not it's
all down to my ability to say this is
the thing I want this is the gap and
skill set between who I am today and who
I need to become in order to acquire
that thing that I want like for me I
want to end uh metabolic disease
globally right so now I I know what set
of skills I need right I'm gonna have to
understand nutrition really well I'm
going to have to understand psychology
really well in order to build this
business I'm going to have to understand
just business in general to get the
metrics right so that people can afford
to buy these products on and on and on
so you can identify the skill sets that
you need and then you get to test them
right because if it's if I have learned
the wrong skills or failed to learn a
skill that I thought I had the business
doesn't grow right so you have this
feedback loop and really my value system
was born out of that I was so so clear
about what I wanted to accomplish that I
could just test uh you know the skills
that I was getting and and that sort of
desire to
accurately assess
and acquire skills really is my value
system right but I think you started
questioning your 34 is that right uh
when do we start Quest starter Quest
five years ago I'm 39 yes well done you
know me better than I do
so how long did it take you to I mean
get clear on what you wanted did it take
35 years 34 years for you to get clear
on what you wanted and what was that
process of actually figuring it out that
you got clear yeah that's yeah it's so
tempting to mythologize everything and
to tell you the the concise story which
is maybe more useful but is a little
misleading so the the truth went
something like this we're miserable
building this company that's a product
we don't care about step one what do we
love what do we care about and what
would we do and love doing even if we
were failing and that was the question
that we asked ourselves so okay the
thing that we would do for three very
different reasons is to make this food
that people choose based on taste and it
happens to be good for them and I've
already explained my reasons
um and so then as you know we're
starting to do the company honestly
you're looking at what's working and
what's not working and you're
relentlessly self-assessing so it was
just clear to me that people didn't
think the way that we thought so the
three of my partners and I ironed Mike
and myself we think a very certain way
right what we call the quest way
and because they had developed that over
the School of Hard Knocks and starting
businesses and failing they were able to
bring me along much later in the process
but because I knew nothing about what
they had learned up to that point and
they weren't teaching me they just
drugged me into deep Waters I had to
learn and because the way my mind works
I was processing that into basically a
list of okay here are the lessons I've
learned I was codifying it right turning
it into a map for Success that I could
hand other people and that ultimately
became the 25 bullet points that are the
quest belief system so as we're going
and I realized in my head I've got these
what I didn't know at the time was 25
bullet points but anyway I've got this
way of thinking and I'm encountering
these employees that don't think like
that and so accepting that there's a
that was really when I started to
realize there's a gap between who people
are and what they tell you they want to
accomplish because in the beginning I
hired everyone everyone right um not
because I'm super smart and thought hey
I should there was no one else right
like we had the smallest handful of
people ever and so I started doing the
interviewing as I was doing it I started
realizing God these guys tell me they
want to do something amazing with their
life and if you just listen like wow
yeah like I want to be on your team dude
you're going to do amazing stuff and
then you realize they can't execute on
that dream so why can't they
they don't have the mindset yet like
there's uh you could do an entire
podcast series on how to get the mindset
but I'll just use Carol dweck and her
amazing book mindset
I'm sure such a good book I see Simon's
the neck up there who is also very
influential on us and she says some
people either believe they're as smart
as they're ever going to be and that's
that so they're going to be ego
protective and they're gonna you know
try to thwart anything that makes them
feel like they're not the smartest
person or whatever and then there's
people with a growth mindset and they
realize I'm not the smartest person and
I'm certainly not as smart as I could be
so even if I am the smartest person ever
lived I could get a little bit smarter
and so when they're confronted with
contradictory information they learn and
they soak it up like whereas other
people are fixed mindset right correct
fixed on like no this is the way and I'm
right and that's wrong yes and I would
say the world everyone's on a spectrum
right even I as much as I believe in it
and work my ass off to be a growth
mindset I still have let's call it 10
where I catch myself I'm like come on do
you know better than that yeah but so
people that fall unless they sub 50
spectrum of the growth mindset it's got
to be 98 rule number five is stop saving
money with jaspreet Singh just like
anybody else
there's checks and balances if the
government has a million dollars they
can only spend a million dollars you
would think but that's not how it works
so the government has a million dollars
and what's happening now is they're
going to spend significantly more than a
million dollars now if you have a
certain amount of income and you spend
more than that what do you do well
you're going to have to subsidize or
find that extra cash somewhere and in
the government's case what they can do
is they can go out and look for a loan
it's called a treasury bond for as long
as anyone can remember have been
considered the safest investment anybody
can make well what it is is you're
literally loaning money to the
government
but what happens now if there's not
enough people out there to loan money to
the government if the government wants
trillions and trillions of dollars if
there's not enough people out there to
loan that money to the government and
they keep wanting to spend more money
you still got to make up this cost so
what do they do they call up their
friends at the Federal Reserve Bank and
they say hey we need a two trillion
dollar loan and then the fed's gonna say
okay we got you now remember what I said
they're not a reserve they don't have a
cash pile anywhere so what do they do
they go to the money printer
and now they can print out two trillion
dollars they loan this cash to the
government and now the government got
the two trillion dollars the federals
are printed it out of nothing the
government can now take this two
trillion dollars and spend it in
whatever way that they want it can be
inefficient they can try to create
efficient products but their goal is to
hopefully help people
now whether they're inefficient or not
is a political debate however you know
that is what they do now really fast
before we move on so this is the part
that people need to understand about why
the rich get richer because I'm super as
a rich guy I'm like oh I'm going to get
richer like what great so what happened
I never understood how so now what
happens you just printed this money
right and then which you don't actually
print by the way you just increase the
database somewhere it's a bunch of
digits yep and now this money enters our
economic circulation but what happens
now when more dollars enter without
actual wealth being created because we
saw this happen in textbook form of 2020
2021 where nothing was being produced
except money
well when more money gets produced it
effectively reduces the value of each
individual dollar this is what inflation
is the word inflation comes from the
word inflate what are you inflating the
monetary Supply so you're increasing the
monetary Supply causing the value of
each individual dollar to go down which
effectively causes the price of things
to go up and so in 2020 2021 no one's
producing however the government is
spending money like crazy where are they
getting this money the Fed so the fed's
printing money giving it to the
government the government's spending it
like crazy now people are getting money
it's people it's businesses it's
corporations
and this money is being spent and now
everybody is like wow I'm sitting at
home and I'm rich you have some people
who are getting big unemployment checks
you have some businesses getting
millions of dollars and everything is
running smooth but and people are
spending money like crazy buying things
but nothing is being produced so then
what happens well now you have a supply
chain mess because everyone's buying all
the stuff in stores however no business
is able to reduce anything because the
economy shut down so the supply chain
issue then you start to see is a
byproduct of the inflation because
everyone's trying to blame oh the
inflation is happening because of supply
chain issues but you have to look at
what is the real root cause the
inflation is what causes the supply
chain issues and now we're trying to go
backwards but this is where rich get
rich and the poor get poorer because as
the value of the dollars drop what
happens for regular people your salary
doesn't stretch as far your savings
don't buy you as much and so you're
effectively becoming poorer each and
every day because for most of us we're
taught to save our money that's what I
was told to do growing up you know the
traditional Indian houses save save
and so I was told to save my money and
your savings are becoming less valuable
each and every day well what wealthy
people do is they're not storing cash
they're buying assets rule number six is
invest in passive income with Robert
Kiyosaki the tax department which every
country has taxes determined they want
to know what kind of income do you work
for
So when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent a parent to the
child
they say it's go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
foreign
income
as you can see from this diagram here
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here and the first
thing you pay is the highest taxes
because you worked for money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees or
invest
okay so earned income is what they work
for the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if I buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand hundred
thousand is capital gains if I buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest text so
the tax breaks that President Trump is
working on today is primarily for these
guys here
so there are doctors lawyers
Highly Educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff are
flipping houses you get a break
but what the really which work for is
passive income and passive income
thank you
for me I have a business whether I work
or not money comes in
and you've seen me I'm not here am I no
I never never
I've earned the right not to be here
real estate I get milk every year my
wife and I can we add more real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still look at this
but this is another type of income
this here I'll get into is called
Phantom income it's taxes I don't pay so
it's a little bit beyond most people's
minds but let's say my tax bill is a
hundred thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break that means
fifty thousand in taxes I don't have to
pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government it went back up
here
so that's what Financial education does
it teaches you
about the financial statement which is
not taught in school again they teach
you FICO scores which is really by those
scores
was you told Lil Dougie okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now ironically
when you save money Ava 401k
this is the kind of income so Savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better it's the saving money in
what he called it 401 cases good in this
in Canada it's called rrsp in Australia
called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
I'm an active investor I don't buy this
because this is passive investors I am
active and I'm professional in all of
these areas
so I work for passive income which means
I'm not here the check comes in the
checks come in every year and you've
seen Kim and I and your mother now
she's working on here and so your
mother's income keeps going up your
father's income keeps going up and they
don't have a job and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is don't make bad decisions
with her meet safety let's talk about
the 150 000 a year and under people
they've been you know working hard jobs
they've been trying to save their money
but it just seems like they haven't been
able to get past whatever it is 50 Grand
a year 100 Grand a year 150k they've
been kind of stuck or they've crossed
100 Grand a year and more problems have
come to them because they're making more
and spending more and they feel more
broke than ever because they have no
clue what they're doing with their
finances still
it's the end of the year they're about
to start a new year soon
and they feel overwhelmed or just
clueless still about and educated about
their money and what what their options
are for just being having Peace of Mind
structure organization and knowing that
they don't distress about it and they
can go earn more and it's going to pay
off for them what's a few
simple things that they should be doing
right now to have a checklist to do
before the end of the year to then Crush
for a whole 12 months moving forward all
right I'm going to give you something
called the ladder of personal finance
which tells you where your money should
go okay this is just step by step put
your money here and if you want to know
all the details about it you can check
out the system so it's in the book too
though it's in great detail in the book
got it all right so if you've got some
money lying around what should you do
with it first of all if you've got a
401k match at work you should Max that
out that's free money take advantage of
it and if you're not sure what that
means go to your HR person and say does
this company match any 401K
contributions if they say yes do what I
said next if you've got Debt Pay It Off
pay it off aggressively you know what's
interesting is that most people in debt
who I talk to don't actually know how
much they owe and that's shocking you
would think of course they would know no
they don't because who wants to
proactive they're dead all day yeah and
just feel bad about it but you know what
you feel much better when you have a
plan and the number one question I ask
folks uh when they tell me they have
debt I say number one do you know how
much you owe they never do number two
for the rare people who say you know
fifteen thousand or seventy thousand
whatever I say what is your debt payoff
date you can actually plug it in you can
pay uh plug in a debt payoff calculator
online
you can map it all out and you will be
able to know the exact month your debt
will be paid off based on how much
you're spending right now based on how
much you're contributing to that debt
payoff now you'll be able to see that if
you add an extra 50 bucks a month or 100
bucks a month that thing will actually
oftentimes shorten by years because of
the interest it doesn't matter if it's
going to take you three months or four
years to pay off your debt it doesn't
matter to me what matters is that you
know the date okay so that's number two
pay off any debt you've got three if
you've got money left over uh go to your
Roth IRA and if you can Max that out
that's a great tax advantaged account it
grows tax deferred is that right yeah
yeah okay so
um so that's three that's three okay
it's actually post tax money and then
four if you still got money you're going
to go to back to your 401k which is uh
another tax advantaged account you're
going to Max that out if you still got
money
you're going to create a non-taxable
non-retirement account and just put your
money in there now there's a few other
wrinkles to this there's hsas available
there's also your emergency fund that's
talked about in the book and all these
things are details but that just shows
you when you've got money this is where
you go there's a structured way of
thinking about it a ladder towards
financial success exactly and if you
follow the steps it's almost like the
like a waterfall it just goes from step
one to step two to step three and your
money's going where it needs to go
automatically and you will feel great
you'll feel great which is so important
and also you're going to look at your
accounts and see that's going down
investment and savings are going up and
all of a sudden you wake up six months
from now and you're like oh my God I
didn't realize I have that much saved in
my savings account that's because of the
decision you made today
let's say you're you know
work on a job making decent money
but you're not really breaking through
and you're struggling to earn more to
get out of that 50k a year type of range
maybe around there and all your friends
are making the same amount all your
peers are in the same boat
and everyone's stressed about money and
you hear someone say well you know you
may earn the average of The Five People
You spend the most time with yeah should
they cut all those five friends out of
their life because like well you know my
peers are holding me back if they're
having those negative conversations or
how can they start to level up yeah
without cutting people out of there yeah
I never encourage anyone to cut off
their friends uh and I think that's a
common misconception that you have to
close all the doors to your friends look
I've got friends from high school junior
high that I still hang out with and uh
I'm not judging them based on their bank
account I even know how much they make
or how much they're worth that's not why
I'm friends but the average of the five
people you're surrounded with that is a
very powerful idea and instead of
closing the door on the people you hang
out with why not open the door to some
new people why not find people who go to
your conference for example or who are
on my site people who are ambitious who
have gone through these programs and say
you know what can we set up a weekly
check-in it could be five minutes it
could be over text
but let's set up this check-in and just
say what'd you want to do last week did
you execute why or why not every week 9
A.M Monday let's do it that's how you
suddenly meet a group of people who are
unapologetically ambitious and that will
change everything for you because
instead of having to drag people to
these self-development conferences and
they say that's weird I don't want to do
it the people you actively seek out
gonna be like yeah I'm in let's do it
let's do it yeah that's powerful yeah so
find the new communities that you can
have these conversations with yeah and
don't cut everyone out of your life but
just start having those conversations
with people that are more aggressive
yeah like do you know what I told people
to do on my Instagram account so I told
people it's important to find other
people who support you a lot of you are
waiting around for some like millionaire
to fall out from the sky and invite you
to their private group it's never going
to happen never instead why don't you
start it yourself and I said go into my
comments write who you're looking for
and then invite someone to join you like
that you don't need to wait no one's
coming to rescue you it's not a Disney
movie nobody's coming it's only you so
take control and go find someone and
then build that together I like that
Cody working on the cameras here asked a
really good question does my opinion on
investing in real estate change if you
live in the Midwest and I think the
answer is yeah it can
the calculus on buying a house in the
midwest is different than cities like
Manhattan San Francisco and L.A so again
the message here is not don't ever buy a
house but it's run the numbers to make
sure that you're making the right
financial decision
if you want to have more money one way
is to uncover the areas where you may be
wasting money and that's why we're
talking about five common ways we throw
money away where exactly did your money
go money is something a lot of us
struggle with check this out in a 2019
employee survey at PWC 71 of Millennials
said their money stress had gone up over
the past year it is stressing me out and
nearly half of all respondents said that
they spent three hours or more every
week thinking about or trying to sort
out their finances and money woes don't
just affect us individually 44 of young
adults said that the money is the number
one stressor in their relationship I
need to borrow some money and check out
these stats according to Erin Lowry
creator of the broke Millennial Blog the
average Millennial graduated with 37 000
in student debt that's in the states and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me Jay hey I get it lots of Us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually help spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that that's why he named his company
seven bucks Productions still even if
you don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
Suz Allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested the 100 or more per
month so many of us spend on coffee in a
lost retirement account over 40 years
with compound interest you'd have a
million dollars what that's worth making
your own coffee right actually the
entire category of food and drink is a
big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520 B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends
2746 dollars per year on lunches now
check this out if instead of buying
lunch you invested that money every
month in a basic savings account over 20
years you'd have hope you're sitting
down because this is unbelievable you'd
have sixty thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars and 41 cents I'm gonna sit
down and that's just two basic
compounding interest okay so here's
another big way we raise money buying
new now here's the thing I know for lots
of us I'll be honest myself included how
we look is important we enjoy fashion
but you can continue to have your unique
look and have favorite Brands and still
spend less money on clothing here's a
way to do that I have another friend
who's into designer Brands but would
never pay designer prices her secret is
to shop at consignment stores and now
that there are lots of these stores
online there are tons of items to choose
from and you can even shop by your
favorite Brands the other month I
complimented my friend on a sweater and
she told me she got it for 65 less than
the original price and it came brand new
with the tag still attached plus
shopping Consignment also benefits the
environment because we're recirculating
clothes instead of just making more
stuff Beyond clothing there are loads of
things we tend to buy brand new that we
really don't need to for example if your
iPhone breaks you can actually buy a
refurbished one directly from Apple for
way less money and they come with a
warranty and don't get me started on
cars here's another quiz when you drive
a new car off the lot it literally
immediately loses a certain percentage
of its value what percentage is it a
five percent B 10 or C 30 the answer is
B according to Carfax the second you
drive a new car off the lot it loses at
least 10 percent in value over the first
year it loses about 20 of its value that
means if you spend thirty thousand
dollars on a brand new car within a year
it's worth only twenty four thousand
dollars and the value just keeps going
down instead of needing everything brand
new look at what you can buy used or
borrowed from someone you know and
that's another way we waste money we buy
things immediately we think of it we get
all excited we go online and buy it it's
like when the Apple watch first came out
and I went out and bought one I was so
stoked but no offense to the product I
discovered pretty quickly just in time
to give it back that I didn't actually
need it I ended up returning it
instead of impulse buying virtual
purchases if you say oh I need to buy
that whatever it may be and then go to
Amazon and buy it and then later in the
day I wanted to get some of that other
thing I loved and then going to Amazon
or another store to buy that what
happens when you get your card statement
it all adds up and you're like whoa how
did I spend that much money I don't
remember any of that and that's because
fifteen dollars here and ten dollars
there doesn't seem like much of the time
especially when you're using a credit
card or other digital payment but you
don't see the money you don't feel it
you don't actually have that experience
of giving it away or holding on to it
instead when you think of something you
need and I'm putting need in quotes
because it might not be a real need but
a want put it in your cart and leave it
there or write it down on a list don't
buy it right away then at some specified
time like the end of the week look at
your list all your cards and choose what
it is you really need that will give you
a better idea of what you're actually
spending and what you actually need
versus what you want another way we
waste money is by passing up free money
a court and you're and you're wondering
what are you talking about according to
investment advisors Financial engines
American employees leave roughly 24
billion dollars on the table every year
in unclaimed money by not taking full
advantage of their employer match on
their 401K the typical employee loses
out a 1
336 dollars per year now look if your
boss said hey we'd like to just give you
1 336 dollars per year you'd be like yes
please right I'm gonna need that in cash
but if you're not contributing the full
percentage that an employer will match
you're basically saying No thank you so
you need to stop missing out on free
money I don't know how many of you have
read dostoevsky's crime and punishment
but I would highly recommend that in
crime and punishment the protagonist
commits the perfect murder and he has
his reasons for it and many reasons
because Dostoyevsky didn't mess around
when he wanted to give someone reasons
he gave them reasons and raskolnikov
that main character had reasons for
murder and then he commits his murder
and he gets away with it
but things don't go well for skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the raskolnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's like it that's the Matrix correct
the red pill
and once there's certain actions once
you take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and riskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you human consciousness is that
faculty that confronts potential itself
I think there's good neurological
evidence for this by the way for those
of you who are scientifically minded
because uh we build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is further
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and then really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worth and
they would probably be better and I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good you have
to expect to suck at the beginning just
expect to suck whenever you're starting
something from the beginning you're
starting a new business idea you're
starting a new YouTube channel you're
launching a podcast whatever it is
expect to suck
most people never start because they
expect to be great and that's a problem
that is keeping you where you are your
addiction to Perfection is the disease
that we need to solve to cure to help
you get to where you want to go and what
you know you're capable of doing so in
my movement makers program we just
started a 100 video Challenge 100 video
challenge you got to make 100 videos
because I think people quit way too soon
I showed people in my group where I was
at 100 videos and I had a couple hundred
views I had three comments on my 100th
video 100 videos in then I showed
garyvee's 100th video and he had 800
views or something and also three
comments and I think we just judge
ourselves too harshly too soon
a hundred videos in I had a couple
hundred views Gary had 800 views
and you're expecting to be great from
your first video
this is a real problem we have to talk
about this I'm all for
Improvement and I'm all for being our
own harshest critic but there's not
enough self-love built into the equation
you just think that you're going to be
amazing from from day one and as a
result when you watch your first thing
you realize wow I didn't expect to suck
that badly you quit I can't tell you how
many people I've seen make videos
and because you know what looks good you
know it looks good right you've seen
other people's videos so you know what
looks good and you think I may not be
that good but I can I can be pretty good
I can do I can do better than that
person and then you press record and
then you see how nervous and awkward and
uncomfortable you are on camera
and then what you delete the video or
you just hold on to it and never post it
that's the problem I didn't like any of
my videos until 350 public videos in 350
public videos was when I finally liked
one of my videos like I you know I'm not
completely embarrassed by what I'm
making right now
and it's that consistency and that
follow-through and I think you can get
there a lot faster than me because I was
introverted and shy and scared and
afraid to get on the camera and all of
it and I just kept going I think most
people can get there faster than me but
it still requires doing the work it
still requires posting the videos and it
all stems from from thinking that you're
going to fail at the beginning it
doesn't mean that you're a failure as a
human thinking that you're going to suck
at the start expecting to suck at the
start actually gives you the freedom to
create to make to go to do to launch to
just do something
it doesn't mean that you suck as a human
it means you're amazing as a human
one of the guys in our challenge who's
become a friend Zane the man Smith so
he's doing his hundred videos he wants
to do 100 videos in 100 days here's a
guy who
procrastinated for a long time in making
videos who had only a couple videos up
on his channel over you know a number of
months
and finally decided you know what I need
I need to do this I need to stop being
perfect I need to start creating so I'm
going to take Evan's challenge of 100
videos inside movement makers and I'm
going to do them in 100 days I want to
do a hundred videos in 100 days and I
was talking to him last night
and he was saying that he still wants it
to be perfect
and it's and it's okay to strive for
Perfection but not at the expense of
actually releasing
so he looks at his videos and he says I
want my videos to to be like Brendan
burchard's videos
okay great but don't expect to be
Brendan burchard from day one
right
it could be the ambition that could be
the hey I love how Brendan intros his
videos or I love the camera he's using
or I love the the the way he delivers
his message or I love the editing that
he's got all that's great to be inspired
by it but to not judge yourself for
where you are right now compared to
where Brendan's at right now in his
content creation how long has Brennan
been doing this for
and before YouTube he was doing speaking
right so how much practice he have as a
communicator and to compare yourself
right now to say I'm not going to
release a video Until It's Brendan
burchard level is ridiculous
but that's the problem that we that we
find ourselves in that's the Trap that
we find ourselves in
you know it looks good you want it
created that level but you don't have
the skills you have to create at that
level and so you stop
and how you develop those skills to get
to that level by doing the work how do
you develop the skills you can't just
read about making YouTube videos you
can't just read about doing squats right
you can't just read about getting on a
diet you gotta actually do the work
if you want to get the results you
actually got to do the work
if you want to develop the skill sets
you've got to actually do the work and
that's the biggest thing most people are
missing because you don't want to suck
if you're afraid that when it shows up
people are going to laugh at you you're
going to laugh at you
you're going to feel less confident
because you want to make something great
okay so how do you fix it how do we
actually solve that problem how do we
get you from that mindset to one
of creating of making a pushing of
expecting to suck at the beginning okay
step one tell yourself I expect to suck
tell yourself that this first video this
first podcast this first book this first
whatever you're gonna do I just expect
it to suck just remind yourself of that
but then praise yourself for it
praise yourself for it for starting
because what you need to do is start
tying your self-worth through
self-confidence your self-love to the
effort you put in daily as opposed to
the results you're praising yourself for
the results that you get you're looking
at that piece of content you're making
that video
and thinking I suck as a human because
my first video sucked no you rock as a
human because you did the scary thing
and you press publish right you posted
it you started it the effort the effort
it was hard to do right you may not get
the result you're looking for but it was
really hard to do if you woke up every
day and did the work that was hard to do
you will start accomplishing some
amazing things if you only started doing
the things that you knew you would
accomplish you're going to live your
life small forever
so tell yourself what the next thing
that you're afraid to do that you expect
to suck at the beginning you just expect
to suck
two remind yourself of who you're trying
to serve and help so what's your message
think about the message you've got for
the world what's your math is your
message only do something when you're
perfect
is your message only do something when
you know it's going to work out think
about who you're trying to reach think
about if you've got kids or future kids
what you want to teach them think about
who you used to be and the message back
to your former self think about all of
that what what is your message be
perfect never do anything until it's 100
perfect no that's not your message
so you have to start living your message
if you want people to actually listen to
you to actually follow through on what
you're saying you can't just talk into a
camera you have to actually be living it
so show me
show me
show me I want to see your first video
and I want to see how it sucks because
here's what's going to happen if you're
starting the 100 video challenge inside
movement makers or just on your own if
you're doing it
and your first video is amazing what are
people going to say imagine what people
are going to say the people you're
trying to serve influence persuade to
live a better life they're going to look
at your first video and say man you are
great from the start well I can't be
like you look at you had all that
natural Talent meanwhile you made that
video 400 times before you actually
press publish on it they need to see
that your first video sucked they need
to be able to look back on your story
and say man look at where you look at
where you came from go back and watch my
first video it's still there didn't
delete it still there you can learn you
can see me sitting down nervous sweating
in a suit trying to memorize my lines
it's a funny video to go back and watch
it's still
you know cringe-worthy for me to watch
it back but I'm also proud that I did it
I was so nervous I was so scared and I
still did it and I still posted it
and then go watch the future videos
and how how poorly edited they were and
how bad I was on camera and how the
lighting sucked and and almost all of
them and the camera was shaky all of the
mistakes that I made you can go back and
watch my journey and see where I've come
from
that's inspiring
I want your story to be inspiring too
but that doesn't happen if your first
video is perfect
so think about who you're trying to
serve
think about your message is to the world
and then actually start living it one of
the biggest things that that
is a roadblock from where you are to
where you want to be
is not the desire is not the idea it's
not the willingness to serve is not the
Heart Right you've got all that you've
got the idea you've got the heart you've
got the ability you know you're capable
of more you know you've got all that
what's the difference
you're just not doing enough
you're afraid to fail
you're afraid of putting it out there
and that nobody will see it you're
afraid of putting it out there and
people will see it and what they're
going to say you're afraid you're living
in the fear Zone and so you have to get
out of it
and you do that by expecting to suck and
you tell yourself I expect to suck and
I'm tying my self-worth to my effort and
you actually Pat yourself on the back
and celebrate the fact that you've tried
and you put it up there
and two you think about who you're
trying to serve this isn't even about
you this is about the people you're
trying to help the people who need to
hear your message the people who will
see what you're making and get inspired
to live a better life themselves the
people who you're trying to solve
problems for
think about them
and I can give you the extra courage to
go off and create and make and actually
build the life that you deserve that
your family deserves and the people
around you deserve to when I analyze
businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I'll put that back over there on my
on my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
uh you need to learn how to manage you
need to learn how to either develop
products you need to learn some of the
technology needs that you have there's a
lot of different hats that you have to
wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company is wearing that hat
right and so imagine if you're um needs
surgery but you're not a good surgeon
what would you do you'd have to find how
do I get somebody who could do the
surgery so for those of you who are not
good at marketing or sales which is the
oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done well to me a
breakthrough is a moment in time it's a
moment when the impossible becomes
possible and you know just think about
it they act upon it you know it's like
you can have a concept that doesn't
create a breakthrough the breakthroughs
and you get to the point where you
actually are going to do something about
it and I ask people all the time I ask
your listeners or viewers as well it's
like I'm sure you've had a time where
you struggle with something right you're
gonna do something about this
relationship but you keep not changing
it right you know pulling back or you're
going to stop smoking or you're going to
go lose those 25 pounds or whatever it
is and you start to make progress and
then you pull back how can you get
disappointed and get frustrated but then
there's some times where finally you hit
this threshold you hit this moment where
your brain says not another day not in
an hour I'm changing this relationship
I'm losing this weight I'm making this
happen and people create that
breakthrough and it can be happen if you
know it's the difference between what
triggers it versus what makes it
possible what triggers it is usually
pain or massive inspiration nothing in
between does it most people they hear
the threshold of pain and say it's like
you know I ask people how many of you
ever been in a relationship way too long
and everybody raises their hand they go
why why just stay you weren't happy they
weren't happy it's just because of the
unknown the uncertainties the the idea
of change it could be worse you know to
be alone but then there's that moment
when you finally hit the threshold you
go it's been painful in the past it's
painful now it's gonna be painful future
I'm gonna change it now so the trigger
that finally made that happen I'd ask
your audience if they think it's
something where they finally broke
through what was the trigger here
usually that moment that day you hit a
threshold of I can't take anymore I'm
changing or
something inspired you you saw someone's
possible and they can do it I can do it
as well but that's what makes it
possible what makes it last is it
changing your emotions or changing your
belief system or a new strategy right
you and I both know because you're both
strategists the right strategy how you
can consume a book and remember more of
it in 30 or 45 minutes than you did when
you used to spend 10 days on the damn
book right you know it's the right
strategy but you're not going to find
the strategy until it's a must for you
not a [ __ ] you know what I mean or it's
that change in belief it's like okay
I've put up with this crap long enough
I'm better than this there's something
more in me that you finally finding
yourself or you finally get pissed off
enough or you get excited enough to make
that real change and so what I've
studied is
I like to take complex things and make
them simple because I found that you
know the more you know when I was really
young I tried to make things more
complex I think to try to convince
myself how smart I was or other people I
don't know what but it's stupid because
complexity is the enemy of execution and
the only way your life changes or your
business changes is execution so it's
like how do you make it simple and I
started looking at all these you know
I've been doing this this is my 45th
year doing this I started when I was two
of course and and I started seeing these
patterns all over the world working with
the greatest people on Earth athletes
business people the most challenged
people in prisons like what are the
common denominators and all these
cultures and I began to see there's
three things you need for a breakthrough
but most of us do them in reverse order
so we don't get the Breakthrough the
number one thing most people do when
they want to have a breakthrough they
don't they want to change their body
they want to change their Finance they
look for a strategy which makes common
sense that's what I used to do
but the problem is
strategy could be the problem and maybe
you need a better strategy but that's
not usually the real problem right like
for example three quarters of America is
overweight or obese if we're the fattest
humans in the history of the world we
all know covid other than age the number
one risk factor is obesity that's number
one and yet very few people do anything
about it and why is that is it because
you know the strategy for being fit and
strong is so complex or only the one
percent know it or it costs a fortune to
do it now you have to be fighting not to
see all the strategies to make your body
physically better around you everywhere
so it's you could have the wrong
strategy like I remember years ago on
the cover of Time Magazine they had the
Atkins diet and they said you know I
think it was 15 of Americans were doing
it well if you gotta pee on a stick so
you don't get too acidic and your breath
is that bad it's pretty obvious that's
not sustainable so sometimes it's a
strategy problem but we work for the how
first and you've never figured it out
your emotions get in the way it's the
wrong sequence it's like the dog bit
Johnny Johnny bit the dog same words
different experience of your Johnny so
strategy naturally is where people go
but rarely do they change with that what
the real problem usually is the story
they've developed and a story is just
code for all the things you've told
yourself over and over again until you
believe them right there's an old a
language pattern that says tell why big
enough loud enough long enough sooner or
later people believe it that was Hitler
said that and so most of us are Hitler
in our own mind so it's not that they
can't you know what do people say how
come a candle is like I can't lose
weight because you know I've tried
everything no if you tried everything
you'd be fit right they didn't try
everything I've tried millions of things
really name them well I've tried Hunters
name them and they'll tell you three
stupid things that don't work that they
did over and over again right so it's
the story I I don't have a relationship
because all the good ones are gone or
they're gay and I'm not or I'm gay and
they're not or whatever the story is the
story is what will keep you like I'm
sure you know Jim you have so many great
strategies you share with people how do
you have times when you give someone an
answer right there in front of them and
they just can't even see it right they
don't believe it because the story is
literally blinding them in Psychology we
call it a scotoma a blind spot
but then there's one level deeper than
even the story
and that's your state the mental
emotional physical state you're in
because when you're in a low mental
emotional physical state
you can have all the brain capacity in
the world but you're not going to use it
and so when you're in a lousy State you
come up with a lousy story and then no
strategy works it doesn't matter what it
is if I don't know if you've ever
noticed have you ever gotten really
angry at somebody and then suddenly you
remember all the ways they've ever
screwed you over you've been upset with
them right but on the other hand you
fall in love and what's wrong with life
nothing I have no money it doesn't
matter we're in love it's all wonderful
right so this is the sequence on which
we do things it's accelerates or
decelerates or stops progress when it
comes to a breakthrough and what I found
is change the state first if you like
when you and I can talk and give people
a million strategies but if I'm sitting
here at home in this state and I'm just
listening like this and nodding like
this yeah that makes nothing's gonna
happen
so the reason that I've done events over
my lifetime and the reason why I do
immersion events you know 10 12 13 hours
a day you learn a little bit at a time
like language you don't remember the
language a few years later but I drop
you in Rome and say you got no teacher
and you got 60 days I'll be picking you
up I'll pick you up 60 days from now
you're going to be speaking Italian
right especially if I put you maybe with
some passionate people who are really
going for it in their life you're gonna
have a whole different state about you
you're going to develop a new story and
you're going to figure out the strategy
so I think the the challenge for most
people especially with covet is we've
all had our state dropped people have
been isolated they've been pushed at
home they've had expectations that have
fallen away like I remember a year ago a
lot of people are like all right we got
vaccines now it's a new year it's going
to be a brand new thing you know 2021
now this year you talk a lot of people I
don't even have any goals or anything
because they've gone to learned
helplessness because they've been
disappointed so many times they start
thinking the problem's forever no
problems forever no war is forever no
pandemic is forever your mind is weak
now and it's gotten a weak habits and
you're in a lowered state so you start
to believe that and so it's like you got
to change people's State first then you
got to give them the story that can help
them they need to give them the
strategies that work in there even if
you don't give them the strategy they'll
figure out their own strategy you're a
perfect example of that right you've
figured it out because you got yourself
to the point where it's like I've got to
turn this around and then you have
something that you can give and that
expands your life as you've experienced
it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want Grant cardone's advice on how to
stop being poor and check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there I believe I'm a spiritual
being Not a Human Being the spiritual
being would have tremendous potential
unbelievable potential it would be the
light on the candle not the candle the
body would be the candle and the
spiritual being would be the flame I'm
the flame